Alright, so first thing I need to do, I'm
guessing, is delete this relationship between band and stage.
>> Right.
>> And if I right-click here. Okay. Delete field. That's was pleasantly
expected. yes. I want to delete the relationship. Gone. Band is on its own
now. That's sad. But band you'll be friends again soon. So then I'm
going to create a new object so that I can, you know, make this whole
thing happen.
>> Right. A new object to be able to
track not only the relationships but maybe other details
about, you know, what time they're playing and what
the status of it is, or something like that.
>> Okay. So set time. Now, this is different because before we've been
naming everything like the band names
have actual names, attendees have real names.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But this set time, we're not going to want to have to name every time.
>> Yeah that feels silly.
>> And so that's when you can change the data type of the
name from text to an auto number. And
the auto number is just an automatically generated number.
>> Okay.
>> Following this sort of.
>>
[CROSSTALK]
Just increments up by 1.
>> Exactly, yeah.
>> So, display format. So can I just like, ST?
>> Yup.
>> Will let me get, okay,
[UNKNOWN].
>> That works.
>> And then are those curly braces?
>> Curly brace.
>> So this means it's going to start.
>> At zero. Er, well, give it a starting number of one.
>> Okay. Like that?
>> Nope, just one.
>> Okay. Yep. And then it'll increment, every time you create a record it'll.
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Exactly.
>> And then Save. Okay. Now, I can add my relationship fields.
>> Right.
>> Let me think about this. Set Time is the child of both band and stage.
>> So I need to have Put the fields on set time.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay. And you can't really have a stage
without set time, so should that be master detail?
>> Both should be master detail, definitely both should be required.
>> Okay,
so we filled that out, and Save. And now
the next one for bands. Hey, that's pretty cool.
>> Yeah.
>> Our relationship here looks like our relationship there.
>> Yep. You've built your first junction object.